hey this is fresh towel Walker can you
figure out the values of a B and C in
this math problem the digits a B and C
are all different from each other and
they are all positive numbers give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution
we'll get started by focusing on the
value for a when you add three two-digit
numbers the most you can get to is in
the 200s so we know that at most a can
have a value that's 2 on the other hand
if we have a three-digit number a has to
at least be 1 to be a positive number so
we've concluded that the value for a is
either 1 or 2 now let's focus on the
value for B look at the numbers we're
adding up in the unit's column we have a
plus B plus C is equal to a result of C
in the unit's column this can only
happen if the values for a and B add up
to something which have the unit's digit
of 0 in other words a and B need to add
up to 10 so if a is 1 that means B is 9
and if a is 2 that means B is 8 so we
basically have two different cases to
consider we either have 11 plus 99 or 22
plus 88 so let's consider each case well
first focus on 22 plus 88 22 plus 88 is
110 we add CC and we end up with the
result of 280 C since 110 has a zero and
the unit's place anything we add to it C
will give us the result of C so instead
focus on the tens place we must have 1
plus C is equal to 8 we can solve this
equation that C is equal to 7 so the
possible candidate here is we have 110
plus 77 but that gets us to result of
100 and
87 we need the result to be 287 so this
is not a solution and this case won't
give us an answer so let's focus on the
other possibility we have 110 plus CC
equals 190 again looking at the units
place won't give us anything because 0
plus C is always equal to C so we look
at the tens place here we have 1 plus C
is equal to 9 this means C would be
equal to 8 and then we'll try out this
possibility 110 plus 88 equals 198 and
this possibility works so to solve this
equation we get the unique result that
this is the answer 11 plus 99 plus 88
equals 198 did you figure it out thanks
for watching this video please subscribe
to my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Locker and if you like this video please
check out my books there links in the
video description